el ministro de exteriores rusos
serguéila en su visita hoy a ankara en
la que se ha encontrado con el ministro
de exteriores turcomeblut Charles ha
amenazado Rusia con romper el acuerdo al
que ese gol julio del año pasado de la
por las exportaciones de cereal y grano
ucraniano en Estambul a través de la
mediación entre Ucrania y Rusia de
Turquía y de Naciones Unidas labrov se
ha quejado amargamente de que Rusia no
puede exportar sus propios productos ni
sus fertilizantes que están bloqueados
en Rusia no porque estén sancionados no
lo están sino porque muchas empresas
internacionales temen comercializar con
empresas rusas por el temor de ser ellas
sancionadas secundariamente ha dicho
labroth que si estas limitaciones o
estos miedos no se levantan en los
próximos semanas Rusia completará
revocará completamente ese acuerdo y lo
eliminará para intentar ella misma
exportar sus propios productos
alimenticios y fertilizantes a través ha
dicho labrov de una Turquía que de
mediadora el ministro de exterior come
bluchalo ha dicho que es el momento
Ahora o nunca de levantar esas trabas
que existen en la actualidad para que
Rusia pueda exportar sus productos ha
dicho a chabu que son muy necesarios por
un mercado mundial muy dañado a través
de una inflación mundial que ha hecho
que los precios de los alimentos
globales hayan subido muchísimo además
los dos ministros se han referido
también al contexto actual de la guerra
en Ucrania ha dicho Chau show que
Turquía teme que las crueldad del
conflicto se incremente en los próximos
días de cara primavera y labrov ha
acusado a Europa de utilizar un régimen
supuestamente nacido en Ucrania para
atacar a dicho labrov a Rusia